so first of all it's a great honor to be
asked to do this it's just a
thing when I when I heard that they were
that the Yale was interested in having
me talk about the first grade stock
market crash I thought well it's
something I love to do it's a it's 300
years out-of-date but the other thing
that I like about this this project
which I'll talk about now is that it's
an interdisciplinary research project
and it really embodies a lot of what
Yale is all about which is collegial
interaction gathering data from many
different kinds of sources literary
sources archival sources quantitative
sources using statistics as well as
using historical analysis so you know
the everybody's interested in financial
markets for sure but this is something
that is also kind of a reflection of the
Yale ethos that I thought would be an
appropriate thing to talk about for this
inaugural lecture series so I'm going to
be talking about a reinterpretation of
all the most famous financial events in
in world history it comes in a year that
most people doesn't ring a bell with
most people so if I said crash of 1987
you know that would ring a bell but 1720
is sort of fishing around in your head
what could it be happening in 1720 why
is that an important date and I hope at
the end of this this period give you a
sense of what makes it interesting and
important and sort of what financial
innovations happened at that time so as
all academic research this project
really starts with a conjecture a
hypothesis to test and to explore and
the broader conjecture why are we
looking at history so far in the past
I'm financial economists by the way I
teach at the Yale School of Management
mostly what I talk about and think about
is financial markets of the present day
but of course financial markets in the
present day we're constantly struggling
with the issue of what causes a bubble
what causes a crash what are the
fundamental factors that underlie
these things and so the thought the
premise of this research is if we go
back to their very first stock market
bubble and we look at the underlying
factors we might be able to learn
something about what all the subsequent
bubbles had in common so that's that's
the basic idea here and the lesson that
the takeaway from the I'll tell you the
conclusion first before I show you the
evidence the takeaway is that financial
bubbles are associated with periods of
innovation in in interesting ways not
just innovate technological innovation
but also we argue together that it's
associated with financial innovation and
so the the first this first market
bubbles is you can think about it as a
laboratory for testing this idea okay so
when I say a bubble I'm gonna sketch out
the parameters for you but this is a
stock market bubble of unbelievable
proportion and it starts out in France
and then it spreads there's contagion it
spreads to Britain and then it spreads
to the Netherlands and then after the
Netherlands it spreads to other parts of
the other parts of the world we've got a
it's got two pieces to it one is the
stocks that are trading at that time
they go up by factors of 10 in one year
earn less than a year and so you know I
can be sitting here with my with my nest
egg all invested in the equity markets
and all of a sudden I'm ten times richer
that's the magnitude of this this this
this bubble and the other thing is not
only was there a bubble in the prices of
stocks at the time but also there was an
enormous new market for new companies we
call them IPOs initial public offerings
all of a sudden people in England in
London were thinking of new ideas for
companies taking these ideas to the
market people would invest in them
they'd they trade in the shares of these
securities and so it was
you know not only if a rise in price but
a spreading of the idea of using the
financial markets to to generate to fund
new ideas new new technologies and I'll
talk a little bit more about that okay
so here's the research background I
mentioned that relates to Yale first of
all first of all my colleague Giron
Horst who's also a professor in finance
at the School of Management he and I
started out on a project together that
sort of launched this investigation and
it started out with a modest goal of
trying to collect some old stock prices
from from from the from Amsterdam and it
kind of grew from there but underlying
this is this project that we have at the
school of management of it's a joint
venture with the bonny key library to
collect old financial instruments a
history of finance and and you know get
the kind of key documents in financial
history as part of Yale's collections so
as you'll see we draw heavily on the
bonnie key library collections and and a
couple of the art of the in the things
that we were able to acquire for Yale
were part of the by Nikki's 50th
anniversary celebration they showed
their great treasures so some of them
were financial treasures and that got me
really excited to have people thinking
about the library not only as a resource
for sort of literary treasures and
Gutenberg Bible but also stuff that you
can study history of finance and history
of business now one of the things that
we do is since we're economists we go
and we collect price data and so part of
this project was collecting old stock
prices from London and from Amsterdam
and Rotterdam as a matter of fact that
really had not been looked at before so
we go back into these newspapers 300
years prior and where we copy out the
stock prices and also actually reading
the old news about why the Moot prices
were moving around so there's a heavy
dose of statistical
analysis as well as archival research
and then we had this project then turned
into an interdisciplinary collaboration
with art historians historians of
theater historians of the people who
study the history of the book and so
you'll see why all of these folks came
together and so the final result of this
project is a volume that we that is
forthcoming it will come out actually
next month from the Yale Press where
we've got the range of people from from
economists to historians to literary
scholars and so forth contributing to a
volume all about this first stock market
crisis okay so I'm gonna start with a
guy a really interesting character his
name is John law and if you've never
heard of him he's he's the greatest
financier that ever lived by certain
measures and it was his kind of
brilliant notion that led to this first
great bubble and ultimately to the crash
but he was he's a Scot Scotsman who was
convicted and imprisoned for murder in
London and in the in the early 1700s he
fled the country and ended up running a
gambling casino to the crowned heads of
Europe and and so he then ended up to be
finance minister of France so this is a
crazy time in in world history that I
come that you know a guy that runs a
gambling casino it actually got rich by
running that gambling casino could end
up running running the finance running
Frances finances but on top of that he
was a brilliant economist and he had a
wonderful idea about how to reorganize
the debt of of France and the idea of
reorganization was take all the French
debt and you exchange it
or stocks so he said you know let's
float a company that actually the
company owns the company that he he
acquired was the company that owned
Louisiana territory so he you know he
owned this great swath of North America
and he said you bring your bonds in the
French debt you bring your bond in and
I'll exchange it for a share which is
which is going to be a worth a lot when
Louisiana really gets going so that was
the whole idea of this I mean if we
could think about how to do that now
I keep thinking right now how could we
solve our current debt crises
what could we exchange you know annex to
lower the debt through some deal like
that I'm racking my brains I can't
figure it out but imagine somebody that
was clever enough to do that now this is
John law and this you can't see this
very well but there is a little guy up
here looking out over the street his
this is John law and this is the
Mississippi bubble so I said it's the
the Mississippi company was the company
that he founded or actually he acquired
and he started trading people when they
got the shares they started to trade
them like crazy so here's the route
kenka POIs in Paris and there are all
these people going nuts just exchanging
shares in this and bidding the prices up
and so forth this street is still you
can still go visit this street it's
fantastic you go to the salt road pumpy
do you know the guess boo bork and you
go to streets right behind that in the
street looks almost exactly the same now
as it did 300 years ago - the throngs
and crowds and so forth so here's what
the company did it starts out this very
low price and all of a sudden when John
law gets hold of hold of this idea of
doing this debt for equity swap this the
shares shoot up like crazy part of its
because they knew that the other people
behind it the deal was the one person
was the Prince Regent so you know the
head-of-state essentially was also a
partner in this they thought how could I
lose and so this notion of investing in
the in the distant future if you will
which is the Mississippi territories
drove the stock price up more than ten
times actually about 20 times and then
you'll see here there was this terrible
crisis which I'll talk about later but
by early 1720 by February in 1720 people
felt like they had made lots and lots
and lots of money okay I just had to put
this picture in to give you a sense of
what they were speculating on you think
of our dot-com bubble you know in the
90s and and people were you know buying
shares and companies that would you know
provide you can sell dog food over the
web and all of this other stuff you
think that's really crazy imagine a
company where the they were betting on
something that here's this settlement of
here's the first settlement of New
Orleans okay and about the time this is
going on people were living in these
weird little hovels in New Orleans they
really couldn't get much going and so
this was completely pie in the sky in
the sense that there was no current
revenue it was all future revenue you
had to believe that controlling the the
the the mouth of the Mississippi River
in the Mississippi River being the the
road into the North American continent
had to in the long run pay off so that
was the idea behind this now I said that
this speculation went on to London in
London you can also walk by the the
South Sea House so the company of the
South Seas that's that's another company
that had speculative interests in in
America now when you hear South Seas you
think well that must be about the
Pacific Ocean you know because that's
the way we think about it now but not at
all it was the South Atlantic that the
company of the South Sea was designed to
exploit and this South Sea house
they're the statues up here
have these great pictures of the Navy
and Indians and sort of this mmm
allegorical motif of the value of trade
in this in the South Atlantic the
company however was one part of the
company of course was kind of echoed the
Mississippi company which is it had the
right to to trade to the extent that the
Spanish would let them in it had the
right to trade with all of South America
but the other thing it had it had it had
acquired the right from the Spanish
crown the exclusive right to trade in in
in African slaves so so this company was
founded on you know this a reprehensible
notion that that that it would get
slaves in Africa or buy them from
another company called the Royal African
company and then trade sell them in in
the Caribbean so people all had this
notion that because the Caribbean
islands for example were beginning to be
sugar islands that really were quite
productive and important economically
slaves were the were the key the labor
was the key ingredient to making that
work and the company in South Seas had
the right to deliver the labor to to to
the Caribbean now the other part of
course was just the same thing that
happened with the Mississippi company
England had all these debts actually
they got debts by fighting each other
and so England how all these debts and
the British said well it's do the same
kind of swap let's do an expected II
will exchange shares in this speculative
venture for the debt of the of the
government so what happened with both of
these cases is the government offloaded
a bunch of debt people that got the
shares expected only a very small
dividend in relationship to the shares
and so it was kind of a win-win
situation as long as the hope of the
Atlantic trade was sufficient to keep
people believing that the that
that the stocks were worth a lot of
money so is that a bubble or was that
speculation on on genuine economic
future value this is a little hard to
see but william Hogarth if famous you
know engraver cartoonists artists print
maker and so forth in Great Britain the
backstory is that he got his his first
great picture that made his reputation
was making fun of the South Sea Bubble
and he did this in 1721 so a year after
the bubble and you can sort of see kind
of strange things going on here's a guy
stripped naked on a on a rack that's the
it's a round wheel or so and he's a he's
a shareholder who's been taking had all
of his money taken from essentially and
he's enduring the agony of the of the
bubble and then there's this
merry-go-round kind of thing with people
sort of suggesting that crazy stuff is
people were going crazy and they treated
it like a carnival the whole speculative
process of bidding up South Sea company
shares well look some at some more of
this in just a minute so I told you that
there were these two bubbles so the
second bubble starts after the first and
actually keeps keeps going you know it
rises to its peak even after the other
one has dropped down so it's a
successive series of speculative thrills
and it goes up quite a bit as well but
likewise ends up in this catastrophic
crash by the way that's just the South
Sea company so here we to have two firms
Mississippi company South Sea company
trading okay this this is a picture that
sort of shows you what we added to that
so up to this point I've just told you a
story that most people that study this
time period know well which is this
story of these two firms so gear Rowan
Horst and I actually our young colleague
Rick Freund who's also who
dutchy he he is a Tilburg University
right now what we did is we said maybe
there's some more information there and
we went to we went to London we got
archived archival material London act
and we found actually a lot more stock
prices some of these were available from
other researchers but some of them we
found on our own and what I want to
point out to you that's interesting
about this picture you see there's also
there's a big bubble that happens over
the course essentially over the course
of 1720 and all the stocks go up and
down right not just the South Sea
company the South Sea company is the
purple dot you can see the the this dark
purple dot here it rises flattens out
for a while then it falls but the thing
that caught our eye were at least two
other stocks one of them is one of them
is called the London Assurance Company
the other one's called the Royal
Exchange Assurance Company so it's not
such a sexy story about like two
insurance company's bubbling you know
it's like what's going on here why why
are these these insurance companies
leading the pack rising much higher
crashing before the South Sea company
crashes right so they crash it crash
actually a couple or three weeks before
the South Sea company comes down and
also if you want to take a look here
notice this orange line this is
something called the York Building
Society this is a crazy company where
some guys bought a shell company that
could deliver water to central London
and then they used it to start and in a
life insurance company where they bought
confiscated estates in Scotland and they
used that the revenues from those
estates to back their life insurance
firm and so these were quite
wheeler-dealer financial engineer types
that even saw an opportunity to
capitalize that company quite well to
get the public to - to invest in that
company and you
and so that's why it sort of starts
halfway through the year they serve they
start their funding process when they
see that the stocks are all going up and
people like to buy shares okay so I'm be
hinting around a little bit but but a
central question is what caused the
bubble and the
if any of you were Robert chillers talk
my colleague Bob Shiller is a behavioral
economist and I am too by the way
I confess I'm interested in psychology
and the stock markets and the the
premise that you generally hear is that
occasionally people go absolutely crazy
they bid stock prices up they're
completely irrational about why the
about the whole process of valuation and
then okay and all of a sudden they come
to their senses something triggers it
and everything goes back down again
a wild madness descends on the markets
and ex-post we realize we sober up and
we realized we were all complete fools
and you know we'll never do it again
that's that's sort of the behavioral
finance story in this in this research
we turn to a different story which is
maybe what's going on is that the North
Atlanta Atlanta trade was perceived as
an economic opportunity with unlimited
potential and I've mentioned talked a
little bit about that already if you
could buy shares in Louisiana now the
whole the whole swath of the the
drainage of the Mississippi and Missouri
rivers you know you might be tempted to
do that but there are a couple of other
things which I hope I'll get to in this
talk and one of them is corporate
freedom during this the years of 1720
one of the things that happened was that
corporate corporations decided that they
were just gonna they were they were just
going to do they were going to go off
the
reservation instead of following the
Charter that they were given by
Parliament - let's say bring water into
central London or pursue fishing
opportunities in the North Sea they said
this corporate form is fantastic it
allows us to raise money plus it also
gives us limited liability so let's just
form a company and then we'll decide
what to do
we'll just pursue any kind of
opportunity that looks advantageous to
us this was a brilliant new idea that
and it made Parliament really angry
because the way Parliament the way
people in Parliament funded itself at
least into individually was they said
well if you want a charter - - for an
insurance company what are we gonna get
what are we gonna get you know we're
gonna get shares what's the trade-off
here so so I mean I'll tell you a good
make a long story short the South Sea
company ended in a big bribery trial and
so when companies took this step to
pursue these various kinds of
opportunities there was a negative
reaction it was called the bubble Act
the Parliament came down hard and said
no more of this issuing of these company
free companies we're gonna be a serious
gatekeepers and if we catch you trading
the shares of these things that we
haven't authorized then you're in even
deeper trouble it's against the law so
I'll show you a little bit about the
effect of that bubble Act in a minute
okay you can't see this too well either
but it's the cover of a book and the
book the book is it was a gift from a
very good friend of mine who said you
know you're interested in finance I
found this old book I know you're gonna
love it
and what it turned out is this old book
contains in some sense the answer to
those questions about what caused the
bubble and by Nicky live
he also has a terrific version of this
book it's called the head karate
Taffarel there dvash aid and it's got
it's in old Dutch and you can see
something constant lighting and so with
art with art plates in common in plays
and in poetry and it was published right
at the end of the year 1720 so most of
this research is just a sort of
meditation on what the heck is this book
why and this book by the way also has
something called conditions in print and
in project and for companies so the book
actually contains a whole bunch of
information financial information that
people just generally skip over it was a
real it was a book that was written to
make to make fun of the stock market
bubble in in Holland and also in France
and England and nobody knows who wrote
the book we know sort of when it was
published it was published anonymously
because it was such a bitter critique
and it was distributed primarily in
Amsterdam but a lot of a lot of copies
exist so in this book
usually when you look at this book you
flip to the hilarious allegorical scenes
and so here would here's an example it's
a picture of all of the speculators
running like lemmings up a hill and over
a cliff and they're following the
goddess of fortune and meanwhile all
sorts of funny things are happening down
here and so it's a picture of of madness
and folly so it accords really closely
to what our current notion is of of what
is stuff what happens there it's not
market bubble sometimes all of a sudden
for no reason people heard they're
following each other and
and it gets them into deep trouble
that's in the book and the book actually
as we look at it we just sort of figured
out that the book is almost a whole
theory about about why a bubble happens
but the theory is not worked out in
mathematical terms it's worked out in
allegorical terms the allegorical
language of the 18th century and so
here's so the this is a second theory
that appears in the book that that that
the the bubble was actually caused by a
mental disorder a brain disorder so it
was mental dysfunction and if you look
at this this is a picture of surgery of
brain surgery in the 18th century the
doctor is got this hat on it's kind of
like the Hat I'm gonna have to wear on
Sunday when we have the inauguration and
then his patient is strapped into this
chair and all of this information is
sort of telling you about the patient
going bankrupt but let's go what he's
doing is he's cutting the guy's head and
the way this worked is that the doctor
would pretend like there was he was
taking a stone out of somebody's head so
he'd make the cut he'd then go like this
and a stone drop out into a bucket and I
will go Clank
and that was the that was the best they
could do in terms of brain surgery in
the 18th century
ok they also thought that this was due
to some evil the influences of evil that
is man's evil nature so here's a picture
from this head brought to Taffarel
of the devil with all it and see all
these things these are shares stock
certificates and the devil is whipping
them on to buy these share certificates
so there's a deep moral kind of view of
this it's the same thing we have now
sort of the first thing that comes to
mind when you hear about a bubble as the
word greed
and one of those sort of seven deadly
sins and and this book really got that
whole well this is the first
articulation of this notion as applied
to the financial markets here's a
picture of John law but he's on his way
he's being carried on the backs of this
shareholder and being sent on his way to
hell so uh you know we've said a lot of
nasty things about financial speculators
over the last decade or so but I don't
think we've quite gotten to this level
of damnation okay so that's the sort of
one perspective that comes out of this
book there's another perspective in this
book however and that's about the
opportunity in the book weirdly enough a
book about the about finance and and so
forth it's got a whole map of Texas in
it so so I'm from I'm a Texan and so the
I was I was kind of shocked that I'd be
able to just that this map appeared in
here I was wondering why looking for
where my home might you know where where
is Austin in this picture and so forth
but the map is in there because of the
Mississippi company and the notion is
hey let's show you actually the the
geographically the grounds for people's
speculative enthusiasm and some of the
Veen yets in this book go into a lot
more detail about the logic of investing
in the Mississippi so here's this fan a
really beautiful little print of the of
the the French trading with the Indians
of the Mississippi River and here the
great mountains of Louisiana that they
have that they're they're exploring
alright
and there's the Mississippi River
spelled all sorts of ways but it's meant
to give you a kind of a bucolic view
this one's a little hard to see but this
is the king and the queen of the
Mississippi they're shown to make you
feel like they're prosperous and
friendly and so forth and then there's
another vignette which basically says
trust me everything there is filled with
sugar and gold okay now I said that
there was a sort of the secret in this
book that really helped understand what
people at the time recognized as the
root of the bubble and so it starts with
this print this is print is by a man
named peacock who was a French print
maker who lived in Amsterdam it's a very
complex and beautiful print but it
starts it's a procession that extends
from a coffee house called the Peng
Kapaa coffee house but it's a coffee
house in Amsterdam and by the way if
you're in the damned and Amsterdam
and you go to the main shopping street
you can see the at least the place where
this was not a coffee house anymore it's
a upscale little shop but you can see
the building that this is and out of
that comes this incredible cart that's
being there with a fortune lady fortune
above there and pushed along by some
stockbrokers and then it the procession
swirls around like this and it goes into
one of three doors the procession of
this stock market goes to either the
poorhouse or the hospital or the insane
asylum so there's a model for you about
you know what what's gonna happen to
speculators and folly is the leading the
cart she's got her skirt tipped up and
then who's dragging the cart that's the
interesting issue here so let me zoom in
on that and actually the the who's
dragging the card this thing was this
print was actually tipped in so you
couldn't see that this in the in the in
the in the channel of the book it made
it very hard to figure out but what
you'll see here is that the Mississippi
company who's already hobbled because of
that early crash is leading the pack and
then the the South Sea company Merida
suit is the is is the other so the that
these two companies were leading the the
the bubble but then as you go back you
can see that there is the there's
a bank involved John law actually
started a bank there is a company in the
back called the West and that company
was the Dutch West Indies company okay
so that was referring to the fact that
this was also a Dutch bubble and that it
involved the Dutch West Indies company
and then finally back here there's the
East Indies company you can see with
this oriental kind of a costume and in
the very back there's this little
character and I'll zoom in a bit and the
characters called assurance so it's the
London assurance company so we've done
all of this work we ferreted out all of
these stock prices we were puzzling
about the insurance company we opened
the book back up again if you look at
really carefully the people at the time
are telling us it's insurance yeah it's
all this other stuff about the Atlantic
trade but insurance is really important
again
why would insurance be important by the
way when we look at it we did our
numbers insurance bubbles a lot compared
to all these other kinds of things the
Atlantic trade bubbled a kind of average
but if we take all the different
companies that we're trading even those
small companies that I don't have price
series for but we can get the bubble
amount it bubbled from other sources we
find that insurance was really big okay
so on to pirates onto to the Atlantic
trade so insurance is important now and
I guess in insurance companies worry a
lot when a boat goes around the Horn of
Africa or goes around the coast of
Africa these days right because the
Pirates attacked the boat
and they they're big payoffs involved
but insurance before 1720 it was
organized typically as a set of
unlimited liability partnerships Lloyd's
of London for a long time was that
organized in such a way that if you were
insuring a a vessel you know you were
somebody that invested in this pool and
if their losses were really large you'd
have to come up with money out of your
own pocket and you could be ruined that
kind of made insurance unattractive for
some for some people who didn't have
infinitely deep pockets and also it
meant that you had trouble diversifying
your risk if you didn't have a lot of
opportunities to pool that risk and so
at the the kind of structure of the
insurance industry was not keeping up
with these the expansion of trade and so
the Atlantic trade involved hurricanes
it involved pirates here's a picture
from Jack Rackham died in 1720 but
pirates were really a big problem
leading up to that to that year and
certainly following okay so you have
these two companies that I mentioned
plus a few other ones that had started
up that we don't have stock prices for
and people's enthusiasm perhaps about
the Atlantic trade but perhaps simply
about the idea that you could create a
corporation instead of a partnership
that could sell insurance really we
think was the root of the excitement
about the prices going up if you had a
corporation you could you had limited
liability that solved one of the
problems if you could raise a lot of
capital from the public markets which
meant that you could create a big pool
of capital and you could therefore
diversify across lots of voyages so the
corporate form applied to insurance was
quite an important innovation a risk
sharing innovation and as you might
imagine it was met with stiff resistance
by all the existing insurance groups but
it was chartered by it was actually
chartered at the same time those two
companies were chartered as the first
two insurance companies in Great Britain
with limited liability by the same Act
that was the bubbl Act which prevented
any more companies from being launched
launched so just when they created this
new financial form for insurance they
shut the door and said nobody else can
do this again now there were troubles
with these insurance companies they they
had in order to get the Parliament to go
along with that matter of fact or I get
the King to go along with it they they
had to pony up a significant bribe and
the bribe had to come in a hurry it was
due in September of the year that the
firms were launched and of course
Parliament was not going quietly about
this whole arrangement a committee in
Parliament was formed in order to figure
out whether or not these companies were
actually following a charter or whether
they're just raising money to write all
sorts of different kinds of insurance
and I'll show you a little bit more
about that in a bit but the Attorney
General issued a writ of ceará fascist
which challenged these companies and and
they hauled him up before Parliament to
explain you know what the heck they were
doing and whether they were following
the rules another couple of things
happen that made these companies created
problems they wrote all this insurance
one of them wrote all this insurance and
then the first time that right out of
the box there was a the whole fleet that
they insured sunk so it was you know it
was a disaster and then there was some
weird burglary that happened
one of the homes of the directors okay a
bit more about where this thing happened
if you've been in London here's the
Royal Exchange you think well that's
where all the stock exchanges were going
on not so they mostly took place in this
little place called exchange alley which
was close to the post office so the news
would come about about being sunk if you
had to wait to trade on it if you said
I'm gonna run to the exchange to trade
on it you'd be too late because
somebody's already trading on that news
halfway along the way okay all right
well so this this this act this bubble
act opens the door to a new form of
financial organization for risk sharing
and then it closes the door immediately
on anybody else being able to copy it so
it took only a couple of weeks for
somebody to figure out that let's take
this idea let's go over to Holland where
there's no law about no bubble Act and
we'll we'll start some insurance
companies over there this guy
Edmund Hoyle puts together a prospectus
and goes over to Rotterdam with another
friend with another associate Gerrard
Reuters and they proposed a rotterdam
insurance company and if you've heard of
it you've probably heard of Edmund Hoyle
before because whenever you say
according to Hoyle if this is the Hoyle
he made a lot of money this is the first
point and only business deal he ever did
he made a vast amount of money issuing
starting this new company he cashed out
after three weeks and retired for the
rest of his life to teach playing cards
and play that's him yeah another that's
right another gambler so another part of
our research saga is we said well if
they started these companies over in
Holland let's find the prices so my
colleague Rick Frey and went over and
dug through people been looking for
these prices for a century
and he dogged Lee went through in every
archive in the Netherlands and he
finally found an archive that had
newspapers that had the prices so for
the first time we could look at the
third leg of this great bubble and the
leg that was associated with this book
that was published in in Amsterdam so
there are a couple of companies that
preceded this is the Dutch East Indies
company in the Dutch West Indies company
and the Dutch West Indies company I
think you can see it here did go through
a point a bubble over the period but
then we also have this Rotterdam company
that starts off you really can't see
much from this picture the reason I want
to show it to you is because it's got
lots and lots of companies on it just as
in Britain they were started they were
issuing all these new IPOs because they
thought this is great we can go to the
public capital markets for new ideas
they have same concept of the freedom of
the corporation that is also jumped the
channel and so not only did they not
only did the idea of Insurance
corporation's come over the idea of the
stock market is a place to get capital
and and and not have to ask permission
for doing business also jump the channel
most of these companies in Holland for
which we collected data are companies
that have city names to them that's just
the way business was conducted in
Holland even the Dutch East India
Company was created by merging the
individual city trading firms into one
and the same kind of structure here we
have not just the you know not just the
Rotterdam company which also issued a
second subscription when the first one
did well but all we have all these
different cities Middleburg and she
demand and an Eden obviously half the
names of the Dutch cheese's that you can
think of are up here okay and also
here's the business they were in almost
all of them in the insurance so this was
an insurance craze but also they said
we'll do other things we'll do other
kind of Commerce
international trade go fishery in the in
the in the in the north in the Davis
Strait and things like that
oops
okay I've told you that part a little
bit about how an IPO worked at that time
you didn't pay all your money down and
buy a share of stock you put down 5% you
got a right to buy the stock okay so a
lot of people could afford to get
involved in the market when you only had
to put a little bit money down in our by
Nicki collection we were able to acquire
which I something which I think is the
only surviving early share certificate
from one of these speculative ventures
and so this is a company that was
started to import timber from Bremen and
Hamburg and so you can see it's kind of
a it is just a little ticket that
allowed you to buy some buy it buy a
thousand pounds worth of this share and
you can see it's set up over here with a
kind of a complicated device that's a
way to prevent counterfeiting of this
thing
oops this is a broadside from that we
have in our Walpole collection and it's
called the bubblers mirror and our
England's folly so England had this is a
list we got a lot of data from this
thing this is a list of all of the funny
companies that were started insurance on
horses for example was one of the
companies a company for the manure ring
of land was was created here's the Royal
Assurance Company the London insurance
company one of the things I thought
would fund here in my day job I study
hedge funds and there's a company called
Wesley's actions actions mean stock
memos chairs okay
Wesley's actions is a company that was
started to invest in stocks okay so to
speculate in stocks so it's that I think
it's the first hedge fund I'm gonna make
that claim
I told you about the Royal Exchange and
London Assurance Corporation Act ie the
bubble Act but it prevents the raising
the transferring of stock transferring
of shares in such stock and that will be
forever deemed illegal and void so how
to shut down a financial market try a
parliamentary decree that says you can't
have any you can't trade in shares so
what happened when that going forward
everybody was grandfathered but you
couldn't sell the shares that you had
this this this document right here
refers to acts passed in this session of
Parliament and so they were hoping that
they that this they would be
grandfathered by that but it turns out
they weren't they would and of course
whenever you say something can't be
anyway there you put whatever you say
something is not allowed to be done okay
well guess what they people probably
trading these things all the time anyway
but but we know that the law had to stop
it prescriptive and descriptive
historical evidence okay prescriptive
okay so of course there's a market
reaction and up to this point before
people who look carefully at the data at
the daily data nobody really could
figure out how the bubble act related to
the crash because the South Sea company
didn't go down for quite some time
before the after the bubble Act so part
of this research was trying to sort
through the events that led up to the
peak and the events that triggered the
crash and our contribution to the
research in this area is to show that
the bubble act caused the crash in this
in the British shares and by the way I'm
plotting here Royal Exchange Assurance
London Assurance but also in the South
Sea company but I'm also plotting
Rotterdam company in the
West Indies company so the Dutch West
Indies companies in this figure and I've
had to put them all on one chart even
though they were in two different
calendars at this time Julian and
Gregorian calendar but I've got it
synched up pretty well and what you can
see is not only either the bubble the
two British companies go up and then
crash but the West Indies company also
peaks at the same time and then it also
crashes so this was an international
stock market crash with contagion that
jumps across the channel so anyway one
of the things you could see is first of
all the bubble act is signed here but
then nobody really knows how it's going
to be enforced
but it was not until the this period
that the Treasury decides to to actually
enforce the bubble Act with this rid of
ceará fast fascist which then caused the
Parliament to call these companies up so
I'm telling the story to a colleague of
mine
Stephen Pincus who's well known here for
writing a book about 1688 he spent some
time looking at archival resources he
goes you know you should go over to the
bikee this is interesting
notebook written by Charles Dillon a who
was the he was a secretary of the earl
of Stanhope and even I'm sure it goes
through daily what's going on with the
South Sea company and one of the
parliaments doing boy that sounds
fantastic so I dash over there usually
okay my office is not too far away I run
over there I get the book I start going
through the notebook and sure enough
there's a daily account of what
Parliament is thinking about and doing
with respect to these companies you
can't read this very well so here's
here's what it says del na is is
reporting back to the early Stanhope who
guys can't be bothered to be to be
around and see the actual stuff for
himself but he says these proceedings of
Lord justices have struck a damp upon
this sort of traffic which is
speculating and imaginary stocks and so
forth and the Sira fascist is the night
one the nicest and most dilatory
procedures in the law
and it'll caused there to be a new act
in other words he's cheering on the fact
that they're able to hammer down on the
heads of these speculators with these
companies with the rid of serif secured
faces so that's that was the 19th of
August we go to the 23rd of August and
then here
he's recounting the actual events where
that York company comes up and the to
insurance companies come up and they
plead to be able to issue new capital
they they need to issue new shares the
insurance companies have to issue shares
because they've got to get Mont cash
more cash to pay off the bribe to the to
the Exchequer and so now Parliament has
really got them where has really got
them where it wants them right it's just
really nailed them these guys aren't
going to be able to fund anything
and so they were obliged to have
recourse to that extraordinary one of
prevailing with them to reassign half of
their stock by the company to be sold
out again in other words they want to
they want to issue water down their
equity to get more cash in and so what
basically is saying is that they've
that's contrary to the intention of the
law which was worked out in the last act
of Parliament says you couldn't go raise
any more money so here we have this
happening on on the 23rd and let's see
if I can you can't see the dates very
well and these are this is Gregorian
dates for a Julian event but actually
that that event happened right at the
very peak so that caused the crash in
these two insurance companies and
somehow the financial crisis that ensued
crossed the channel probably because
investors in Holland we're investing in
both both of these you know investing
overseas we don't know exactly the
mechanism for that that that that that
chain but it's funny because the
drop in the West Indies company in
Holland follows just three days after it
happened in London and that's the length
of time it takes for a boat to get back
and forth okay so in the end what
happened
France restricted its markets England
restricted speculation Holland actually
the trading all stopped the stock
markets took a hundred years to get back
to where they were so it killed equity
IPOs it just killed them in those three
countries for a century but the
insurance company actually survives and
I'll show you a little bit about it this
is a share in the Rotterdam insurance
company of 1720 sheer certificate that
my friend Ron Horst has and then the
company still exists assurance Rotterdam
basically here's a here's its website
it's still selling insurance policies
okay and so it's the oldest continuously
operating corporation insurance company
in in Europe that was the product of
this period of extraordinary innovation
and you know sometimes yeah a lot of
things didn't work the maneuvering of
land that one didn't survive but the
innovation in insurance did so anyway
I'll end with a cover of the book
because I've just gotten an advance copy
so but but this book tells much of that
story and it's a book about the book so
it's it's as I said it's work that
involves not just geared and myself but
also Katharine Lobby Oh who's a French
literary scholar and Timothy young who's
the who's a curator at the Bonnie key
library